hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen kleinen serie eventuell die
ich mir da ausgedacht habt und zwar zehn
crafting ideen in minecraft also rezepte
die eventuell mal hinzugefügt werden
könnten die coole sachen hinzufügen und
die ich mit so ein bisschen im internet
nachgeschaut habe oder ein paar coole
gefunden habe oder mir ein paar selber
ausgedacht hat und euch die einfach
zeigen wollte euch fragen wollte was ihr
davon haltet und ihr könnt mir auch neue
rezepte in die kommentare schreiben die
ich eventuell aber vorstellen soll
ihr könnt mir schreiben dass ich eine
serie besser machen kann alle möglichen
sachen aber ich würde sagen wir fangen
direkt mit den zehen rezepten die ich
mir da so überlegt ob die ganz cool
während das erste rezept ist ein stift
und zwar kräftig man diesen stift in dem
man auf die linke seite 3 holzwaren
boden klenks rein packt das ist egal was
für welche rechts kann man auch egal was
für welche reinpacken und in die mitte
in die mittleren drei kommen drei sticks
dann kommt man bekommt einen ganz
normalen stift raus und diesen stift
kann man dann auch noch nachher wenn man
möchte kann man den mit ihnen die rother
wolle zusammen ins crafting feld packen
dann bekommt man zum beispiel in roten
stift da kann man den stift wieder mit
blauer wolle reinpacken und man bekommt
dann irgendwie im blauen stift oder mit
blauen farbstoff oder mit roten
farbstoff da gibt es ganz ganz viele
ideen also das ist crafting rezept
nummer eins von dem ich denken würde
dass auf jeden fall cool wäre und man
mit dem stift dann quasi ihr kennt ihr
diese paintings dass man quasi wenn man
rechts gedrückt hält auf seinem painting
einfach selber was drauf machen könnte
könnte man sich richtig coole sache mit
überlegen also soll pencil minecraft
wäre auf jeden fall richtig cool das
nächste crafting rezept besteht aus
sieben eisen einem redstone und einem
glas und dann bekommt man nämlich eine
kamera und zwar ort nennt man die ganzen
dinge so an wie es quasi gerade schon
seht also sollen quasi im crafting table
aus eisenbahner in die mitte ein
redstone quasi um den motor
beziehungsweise diese engine diese sind
akku etc darzustellen und das glas vorne
für die linse und dann bekommt man eine
kamera mit der man ähnlich wie mit f2
hat quasi fotos machen kann allerdings
die kamera hat man in der hand und kann
man wie beispielsweise wenn man
irgendwie eine karte hat oder so und man
runter guckt ist man in der kamera drin
bzw wenn man rechts gedrückt dann hat
man quasi sonnenfenster aber wo das
wasser aus der zeit man so eine kamera
in der hand also das dann oben so ein
rekord button
und da kann man in sachen einstellen wie
die helligkeit oder den kontrast oder
die belichtung dass man ganz viele
sachen einstellen kann also mit f2 in
minecraft kann man ja nur ganz normalen
screenshot machen
aber mit dieser kamera kann man dann
ganz das ganze noch heller machen ein
bisschen dunkler eventuell ein bisschen
rötlich färben auf jeden fall ganz ganz
viele neue funktionen und eine kamera
minecraft auf jeden fall richtig cool
damit man nicht mal diese elendigen f2
screenshots hatte die dritte kräftigen
idee ist ein fernseher und zwar gibt es
ja schon den frühling mod und da werden
ja auch fern tvs hinzugefügt es gibt ja
noch andere teile vision mods in
minecraft
allerdings habe ich mir gedacht dass es
ganz cool wenn man eben mal einfach so
als dekoration hinzufügen könnte
es gibt ja mittlerweile immer mehr
dekoration da gibt es jetzt auch noch
flower power zeit da sind ja auch alle
dazu gekommen sondern fernseher aber
auch ganz cool würde ich sagen und zwar
orte man erstmal eisen als wird man sich
eine hell machen dann packt man ein glas
rein für das display des fernsehers und
drei redstone diesmal als engine also
die kraft in sachen die man dafür
benötigt die items sind so ein bisschen
wie mit der kamera an der kamper
funktioniert ähnlich wie ein fernseher
beziehungsweise ist funktioniert nicht
ähnlich aber es ist eigentlich schon
ähnlich also seine linse ist ihr wisst
was ich meine jedenfalls kann man auf
dem fernseher an verschiedene programme
auswählen
es ist halt quasi genauso wie in
painting nur dass das ganze was da drin
ist sich bewegt also quasi eingriff
animiertes painting und ist mir auf
jeden fall auch richtig cool wenn das
hinzugefügt wird
die dritte sache ist ein klavier und
zwar
es gibt total viele musiker mods und
auch dinge die klaviere und instrumente
hinzufügen und es gibt auch leute die
schon komplett ein klavier oder ein
piano mit redstone nachgebaut haben
allerdings wäre es ganz cool wenn man
das einfach mal selber bauen könnte dann
hätte man quasi oben links ein iron und
oben rechts ein iron oben in der mitte
ein lehrer quasi für diese ganze tasten
dann in die mitte natürlich not blog
natürlich was auch sonst
links und rechts red storm wieder für
die engine und unten drei holz barren
holzblöcke einfach weil sein piano
eigentlich immer aus holz gebaut ist
oder so ein klavier oder halten flügel
und dann bekommt man drei entweder drei
von diesen klavieren und die stellt man
dann halt nebeneinander oder wenn man
das doppel drei pakte erhält man als 6
und kann ein doppeltes klavier bauen und
da kann man einfach mit rechtlich auf
die tasten draufdrücken kann dann
verschiedene töne erzeugen genau sie mit
dem notebook nur bei einem notebook ist
es ja so wenn man drauf klickt angeht
dann und ganz auf das immer höher
aber da kann man dann halt beliebig auf
die tasten draufdrücken dann eventuell
einen eigenen song komponieren kopf
kommt komponieren genau wann wir zu
fünft sache und zwar es ist eine flasche
es gibt schon water bottles also es gibt
ja schon diese bottle teile womit man
wasser und lava will kann und es gibt
auch schon wasser einmal die man aus
drei glas macht allerdings gibt es noch
nicht wirklich etwas was man trinken
kann das ist ja das was ich schon oft
gesagt habe es gibt zwar hungern
minecraft aber es gibt keinen durst und
ich finde es sollte jetzt nicht eine
neue leiste hilfe dort durst hinzugefügt
werden sondern wirklich einfach das
durst auch den diese hunger keulen
darauf führt und zwar halten bisschen
weniger dann aber dafür halt auch dass
es dann auch den hunger auffüllt und
zwar kräftig man sich das ganze einfach
indem man zwei eisen übereinander packt
dann hat man so eine flasche und diese
flasche damit kann man dann zum beispiel
die flasche kann man mit einem apfel zum
beispiel ins crafting fall 13 hat man
sowas wie apfelsaft oder wenn man das
mit kakao bereit und hat man einen
kaffee oder irgendwie ein kakao oder so
da kann man auf jeden fall sich ganz
coole sachen ausdenken und das wäre
meine kraft in der nummer 56 ist ein
stuhl und zwar wurde dieser auch schon
mit dem freundin charlotte hinzugefügt
oder es gibt ja auch schon ganz viele
machen wie beispielsweise bei minecraft
galaxy konnte man sich auch stühle
machen etc ist es ganz einfach zu kaufen
man muss er glaubt nicht mehr viel zu
sagen
drei holz blanks einfach und darunter
zwei stecker und diese stärker sondern
qualitätsstufen und das andere
das erklärt sich quasi von selber man
kann einfach auf den stuhl machen kann
sich da drauf setzen und sitzt dann
quasi und es hat quasi gar keinen sinn
aber hey man hat ein stuhl nächste sache
finde ich sehr sehr cool und zwar ist es
ein lava mülleimer weekends allem an
macht irgendwie wenn man spielt irgendwo
lava hin und schmeißt er seine sache
rein wenn man irgendwie ganz gerade hat
oder ganz viel cobblestone oder
allgemeinheit ganz viel was man
loswerden will
das kann man sich jetzt allerdings was
heißt jetzt also wenn das eingefügt
werden würde werden würde tun sollen
kann man einfach siebenkotten die
zusammen bucket anordnen
in die mitte ein lover und darüber diese
falltür und dann bekommt man einfach
einen kumpels von block wo drin lover
ist also ähnlich wie dieser wasserkessel
und darüber ist quasi ein eine falte die
man auf und zumachen kann dann macht man
die auf schmeißt die sachen rein die
alle sachen sind alle weg und man macht
die falte wieder zu und der müllers
wieder zu dass es viel viel geiler als
einfach irgendwo einen lover becken zu
machen und einmal die sachen rein zu
schmeiß kommen wir jetzt zu einem neuen
power schwert und zwar kann man einfach
sich zwei die schwerter kräften die
nebeneinander so wie ich gemalt habe
angeordnet habe in photoshop kann man ja
einfach nebeneinander ins crafting fällt
und man bekommt ein laserschwert also
das ist einfach ein ganz normales wert
was die doppelte power von und diamant
schwert hat also wirklich ist kann alles
klitzekleinen panischen außerhalb
liegenden ender drachen oder keine
ahnung was es noch besonders starken
eisen golem oder irgendwie sowas aber es
sieht halt einfach viel pompöser viel
mächtiger aus es leuchtet außen rum so
blau dass habe ich da auch angeordnet
ist halt so ein bisschen glück hat quasi
wieder laserschwert und es hat einfach
eine krasse power mir schon zuvor
letzten sache und zwar es ist ein ossi
cobblestone in moskau will stone ich
weiß gibt es schon allerdings kann man
sich diesen noch nicht kräften
man findet ihn nur wenn man irgendwie in
dungeon geht oder wenn man halt
irgendwie ins bonner findet dann findet
man also 30 mosley cobblestone aber wenn
man irgendwie was ganze ist eine alte
verlassene burg bauen möchte und man hat
einfach keinen musik cobblestone und ist
gerade im gaylord 0 und kann sich der
nicht bieten kann man auch einfach diese
ranken nehmen und die mit kumpels
downloads inventar pins crafting feld
tun da bekommt man moskau based on ich
weiß nicht warum es immer noch nicht
hinzugefügt wurde weil es ist liegt so
auf der hand dass man sowas einfach
machen kann
aber es wird irgendwie man hinzugefügt
also das wäre auf jeden fall richtig
cool wenn das auch noch kommen würde
wir sind schon meiner letzten ball
herangekommen ja und zwar ist es ein
over bogen wir hatten vorhin schon das
opfer beschwert der bogen ganz einfach
wird ja eigentlich ausblicks gebaut wie
es hier geht anstatt mit den diamanten
allerdings sei man das mit den diamanten
baut bekommt man quasi so was ähnliches
wie der lega bogen ihr kennt
wahrscheinlich noch den legria bogen aus
damals minecraft hero der zwei pfeile
geschossen hat oder waffeln crepes und
ich glaube das war der legria bogen und
dann gab es noch diesen großen bogen
frohsinn terror keine ahnung der
sonderfall geschossen hat womit der
gegner verlangsamt wurde und das ist
quasi beides in einem und zwei schießt
dieser bogen zwei pfeile und diese
beiden fälle sind richtig eisern und
machen dem gegner auch noch mal
langsamer also ein richtig harter bogen
und ja das fahren ist man die kräfte so
freunde ich hoffe euch hat das ganze
video gefallen wenn es euch gefallen hat
zeigt auf jeden fall mit einem mag ich
und wenn ihr mehr davon haben wollt dann
könnte es mir einfach meine kommentare
schreiben und bitte schreibt noch neue
crafting rezepte wenn die wirklich mehr
davon volt neue crafting rezepte unten
in die beschreibung weil bisher war so
ich habe mir von den dingen ein paar
selber ausgedacht ein paar habe ich
einfach im internet gefunden weil
dadurch bin ich darauf aufmerksam wurden
zwei sachen habe ich in einem anderen
video von irgendwem amerikaner vor drei
jahren war schon mal entdeckt ich hab
halt einfach ein paar sachen zusammen
gemütlich bisher am coolsten fand
allerdings lebt ab jetzt die serie von
euren crafting gesehen
das heißt schreibt mir in die kommentare
irgendwie soja als wäre ganz gut wenn
man das und das machen könnte dafür
macht man links zwei davon hin und
rechts war darf und dann bekommt man das
raus und dann mache ich eventuell noch
mal so ein partner von der kommt jetzt
natürlich nicht die nächsten tage weil
das ganze
menge an bearbeitung et cetera dauert
allerdings ich würde sagen ich hätte auf
jeden fall bock nochmal so etwas zu
machen wenn ihr auch bock drauf habt
dann lasst es mich wissen scheine
kommentare wir sehen es beim nächsten
mal wieder einmal gut und ciao